ربما تتخيلون ان هذه المشاهد لتعذيب
السكان في احدى المدن لكنها ولغرابه
احتفال بانتهاء موسم حصاد الفواكه وامل في
حصاد وفير للموسم المقبل
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عادات وشعوب
بدايه او نهايه موسم الحصاد مناسبه
احتفاليه مهمه لدى العديد من شعوب الكره
الارضيه المهتمه بالزراعه تقام مهرجانات
وغيرها من الطقوس املا في موسم حصاد وفير
الثمار وغدير الانتاج او شكرا وعرفانا
لانتهاء موسم الحصاد بنجاحه لكن بعض هذه
التقاليد لافته في غرامتها هنا في مدينه
سلفادور يقام واحد من الطقوس النادره
للاحتفال بالحصان المئات من سكان المدينه
حملوا حزام الفاكهه على ظهورهم واكتافهم
في ساعات الصباح الاولى مستخدمين الاعواد
الخشبيه بشكل فريد ربما هو الوحيد من نوعه
في العالم
سجون لايطالي
[موسيقى]
انواع الفاكهه التي تم حصاده
من الامور التيته ايضا في هذا الاحتفال
ارتداء المزارعين اقنعه على وجوههم تمثل
الشيطان لابعاد شره عن المحاصيل اضافه الى
اقنعه لشخصيات من الاساطير المحليه اثناء
السير بصحبه الفواكه هذه الطقوس تستمر
لايام وتنتهي مع فجر اول يوم في شهر يونيو
حيث يتم تعيينه مسؤولين جدد لتنظيم
الاحتفال في العامل
شاركونا ارائكم ما هي اغرب طقوس الاحتفال
بموسم الحصاد التي شاهدتها
[موسيقى]